[Musique]
derrière chaque geste de tri dans nos
bacs jaunes à la déchetterie ou dans
l'industrie se profile une filière de
recyclage
un embryon d'économie circulaire se met
en place en valorisant des matériaux
contenus dans nos déchets ici à orléans
le brgm bureau de recherches géologiques
et minières mais ses savoir-faire issus
de l'exploitation de la mine au profit
de la valorisation de nos rebuts de
citadins on parle alors de mines
secondaire ou encore de mines urbaines
temps cela est lié à l'activité humaine
une recherche appliquée qui s'investit
dans nos vieux ordinateurs riche en
minerais aux gravats de béton issue du
démantèlement d'enceinte nucléaire ou
encore dans le traitement de déchets
miniers
même si aujourd'hui la france ne compte
plus de mines en activité
le brgm conserve son expertise sur le
minerai d'où qu'ils viennent y compris
de nos poubelles sur le site d'orléans
une trentaine de projets de recherches
mobilisent les scientifiques dans
l'unité déchets et matières premières
c'est vraiment le minerai sécher broyer
donc être écartée jusqu'à 2 kg donc sur
lequel ensuite on devait faire la
différence d'expérience dans lequel on
va pouvoir récupérer donc il ya majorité
mais aussi de la pyrite qu'on appelle de
la visite dans don composé après en
frères souffrent ces déchets miniers
sous forme liquide arrive de suède ce
qui reste après l'extraction
industrielle recèle encore du potentiel
on peut voir dans ce déchet
il y a beaucoup de pourcentage de fer
qui peuvent être relativement
intéressant parce qu'il reste encore 20
% de fer présent dans ce minerai
illégalement du cuivre qui autour de 0
20% mais qui est toujours réutilisables
par la suite la recherche scientifique
doit maintenant trouver un procédé pour
une deuxième extraction de minerai cette
mine secondaire ce sera le projet nemo
productions plus récentes de l'activité
industrielle les led
apparu il y a dix ans commencent à
arriver dans les bacs de récupération
ces lampes en fin de vie sont un vrai
casse tête pour l'entreprise de
recyclage mtb qui a fait appel au brgm
là il ya que des lampes led normalement
oui on voit bien d'ailleurs est petite
elle était si on obtient vraiment la
fraction ici
tout
broyé et donc là on voit vraiment toutes
et tous les éléments sont libérés
voyez-vous de quartier etc ce sont donc
les morceaux de cuisine et les
technologies et matériaux des lampes led
n'ont rien à voir avec les anciennes
lampes à incandescence la collecte de
ces lampes à diodes commence à avoisiner
les mille tonnes par an aujourd'hui a
pas de recyclage
la grosse difficulté c'est effectivement
toute la complexité des matériaux qui
composent une lampe à led le produit
donc tu as tout ce qui est inférieur à 5
et tu vois là on a des défis l'oci un
petit peu là les gelées des lumineux la
des lampes retrofit on voit aussi un
petit peu d'aluminium et ouais tu peux
avoir un peu de vert aussi voilà c'était
ça c'est vraiment laminak tronic nous
non c'est plus tard pour la tri s'est
lampes led broyés par l'industriel vont
intégrer un projet de recherche cette
fois en laboratoire retour à orléans
l'unité déchets et matières premières du
brgm a été créé en 2010 dans ce service
chercheurs ingénieurs et techniciens
applique les méthodes de la science au
recyclage dans ses laboratoires déchets
miniers déchets industriels revue
électronique ou déchets du bâtiment se
métamorphose en ressources minérales
réutilisables dans l'industrie
l'économie circulaire s'invente ici
cette mine urbaine elle a plein de
raisons je dirais pour pour prendre de
l'importance même si ça reste encore à
construire et que ça reste un peu un
voeu pieux aujourd'hui faut le
reconnaître
d'abord il faut bien se rendre compte
que la quantité d'éléments qu'on
mobilise dans nos technologies
aujourd'hui elle est nettement plus
importante que ce qu'on a utilisées dans
tous les décennies et les siècles passés
donc on a un besoin aujourd'hui en
ressources qui est colossal
c'est pour répondre à notre transition
numérique aux usages du numérique tous
les jours dans nos vies c'est pour
reprendre répondre à la transition
énergétique pour aller vers une économie
bas carbone
c'est pour répondre également à la
transition écologique donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est
finalement structurants essentiel pour
nos projets de société et donc bah si
une fois qu'on a posé ce constat si on
s'appuie uniquement sur des ressources
nouvelles sur des mines on se rende
compte que d'une part on va faire face à
un moment à l'épuisement des ressources
d'autre part évidemment les activités
minières souvent faim pendant tout le
temps où un impact environnemental même
si on cherche à le minimiser
donc assez naturellement émerge l'idée
de se dire finalement nos objets en fin
de vie typiquement est ce que leur mais
la meilleure solution le meilleur visage
qu'on puisse en faire c'est vraiment
d'aller les mettre dans un stockage dans
une décharge est ce qu'on n'a pas mieux
à faire on réutilise en ces matières qui
sont présents dans ces objets et cette
recherche de matières valorisables
justement c'est la raison d'être du brgm
depuis sa création
jadis focaliser sur le sous sol
désormais le service géologique va
chercher le minerai
où il est c'est à dire dans nos
poubelles on valorise les étapes de
traitement initialement
utilisé dans l'industrie minière pour le
recyclage de ces déchets qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs rumine ses mines urbaines
mais c'est une mine puisque on se rend
compte que finalement toutes les
techniques qui sont utilisés dans
l'industrie minière comme les techniques
de tri physique par exemple la
séparation magnétique même
interdisent âge
- une séparation des fractionnements
ferreux on voit qu'elles sont efficaces
également pour traiter ces déchets la
mine urbaine nos déchets électroniques
par exemple sont très riches en minerais
c'est par tonne que sont broyés nos
vieux disque dur d'ordinateur un carnage
mécanique destinée à récupérer un tout
petit bout dément contenant quelques
grammes de ces précieuses terres rares
c'est une mine parce que vous voyez que
dans un disque dur comme celui ci vous
avez un certain nombre de métaux et en
particulier ce qui nous intéresse dans
ce projet c'est de récupérer ceux ci
donc c'est ce genre de plaquettes de
freins qui contient des thés rares donc
l'europe est complètement dépendante des
approvisionnements en terres rares et
celles ci sont produites à plus de 98%
par la chine d'où des tensions sur sur
cet approvisionnement est le vieux
continent est totalement dépendante de
ses approvisionnements pour son électro
mobilité et la transition écologique
d'une économie basée sur le pétrole
on bascule vers une économie des métaux
rares gallium cantal lithium cobalt où
qu'ils se trouvent sont indispensables à
l'économie du 21e siècle
retour à l'opération nemo là le
recyclage des déchets de minerais ne
roulera pas des mécaniques
ce sont des bactéries qui vont faire le
travail derrière ces sacs de poudre
grise se cache 8 milliards de tonnes de
déchets produits par des siècles
d'extraction minière
rien qu'en europe donc là on a surtout
une bactérie en particulier qu'a un peu
note bactérie e superstar qu'on appelle
leptospirose hommes ferry fils sommes
donc c'est une bactérie qui travaillent
sur le cycle du fer toutes ces
installations donc un but
chouchoutez leptospirose hommes cette
bactérie hors norme se plaît dans les
sources d'eau chaude se nourrit de
l'oxydation du fer et tri pour nous les
déchets de minerais il n'ya plus qu'à
ramasser les bactéries vont contribuer à
la pression de produits chimiques au
bond à les dégrader la matière m ont
solutionné métaux qu'on recherche qu'on
veut convercité voilà sans les bactéries
en fait tout se passe au sein du
laboratoire à la mine il y à la
recherche appliquée à partir de sa
bactérie superstar l'équipe du brgm
conçoit un procédé de recyclage des
déchets milliers cette fois grand format
on a essayé d'imaginer quelque chose qui
coûterait beaucoup moins cher et on a
imaginé un nouveau concept de
bioréacteurs ou en fait on va creuser
des bassins dans le sol et on va
utiliser ce qu'on appelle des agitateurs
flottant pour agiter la pulpe est
injectée l'air dont les bactéries ont
besoin pour leur croissance et leur
activité
invention destinée à recycler au plus
près de la mine et de ses déchets venus
du passé
en france chaque année le secteur du
bâtiment produit 20 millions de tonnes
de gravats des déchets de béton
longtemps enfouis
aujourd'hui ils sont réutilisés très
partiellement comme graviers en
sous-couche routière ces déchets
contiennent pourtant un élément précieux
le sable la nature a mis des millions
d'années à fabriquer ces granulats leurs
prélèvements en carrière ou en rivière
dégrade et modifie les écosystèmes
recycler les gravats pour retrouver
cette matière première est au coeur d'un
projet de recherche pour le secteur
nucléaire
il ya un enjeu sur ces bétons parce que
il ya des quantités importantes qui vont
être produites dans le futur puisque les
centrales nucléaires vont être démontés
un jour est démolie et donc il va y
avoir des quantités importantes de béton
à gérer et comme c'est du béton qui peut
être très faiblement radioactifs ou
radioactifs
il faut savoir le gérer intelligemment
et le stocker dans un espace dédié dur
comme de la pierre le gravats ne
restitue pas facilement les éléments qui
le composent
c'est un béton synthétique qu'on a fait
fabriqués exprès pour le projet qui
déparent radioactifs autrement je ne
tiendrais pas comme ça il est constitué
de granulats naturels qui proviennent de
carrière de sable et de ciment
notre but c'est à arriver à séparer
chacun des constituants du béton pour
pouvoir après le stocker de manière
optimisée dans le centre de stockage de
séparer d'un côté des granulats propre
qui ne sont pas polluées par la
radioactivité et d'un autre côté la pâte
de ciment qui est enrichie en
radionucléides
s'ensuivent des mois de recherches pour
inventer une recette simple cuir le
béton les bétons on a ici dans cette
machine la bohalle et nova pour
micro-ondes
c'est le même four micro-ondes que ce
qu'on a dans nos cuisines mais avec
beaucoup plus de puissance et les bétons
vont cuire et ils vont être fragilisés
au coeur même de la matière et après on
va pouvoir les concasser et ça va nous
permettre de séparer plus facilement les
granulats de la pâte de ciment
le micro-ondes n'enlève pas la
radioactivité mais le ciment et le sable
prennent moins de place et peuvent même
être réutilisés comme matière première
pour de nouveaux bétons
toujours dans le secteur nucléaire là on
a obtenu des granulats propre qui se
ressemblent aux granulats naturels qui
ont été prélevées au début quand on les
voit bien la sphère qui sont propres il
n'y a pas du tout de ciment dessus les
bétons tu retourneras béton
[Musique]
réduction de l'impact environnemental
indépendance économique
le recyclage montre de multiples
intérêts mais aussi des limites
l'activité humaine sur cette planète
consomme des ressources tout ce qui nous
entoure
absolument partout dans nos vies privées
pro etc novelli culte ou sort du sol
absolument tout et avec l'augmentation
du nombre d'habitants sur cette planète
et l'augmentation moyen du niveau de vie
il est clair que une croissance donc
croissance économique lé clair que pour
alimenter ses économies nous avons
besoin du secteur primaire nous avons
besoin de la mine le recyclage seul ne
peut pas produire les matières ne peux
pas répondre aux besoins en matière d
économie
le rêve d'une économie circulaire qui
consommerait juste ce qu'elle recycle
s'effondre au regard de la science
l'utopie du zéro déchet se heurte au mur
des lois physiques et de la société de
consommation